hey guys Ryan right here and I'm Jerry
so gonna check out that what are we
doing Rizzo random Brazil random
youtubers I know we're so saying they're
so unpredictable our energy is like hyah
speaking of xenian unpredictable seth
macfarlane oh boy but he's known for
that yeah we got the trailer here for
Ted too red band trailer it's the second
one so let's see this people were mad
that I wasn't laughing hysterically at
the first one yeah I think I was they're
like you don't have a sense of humor off
of one trailer I lost all respect for
the internet like everybody assumes that
if you disagree with them you you
disagree with like all comedy yeah
exactly what people don't know is that I
like the first head I recommended it
when I saw the trailer I didn't think it
was gonna be funny like you didn't look
like a funny movie Jerry didn't look a
funny movie but so I like the movie
though get the boss on the phone let him
know it wasn't gonna be an epic crude
and sexual [ __ ] pervasive language and
some drug use oh boy see we didn't know
this is Ted tear this would be a wattage
yeah this news tree my dealer gave me
called helped me get home hey guys put
some trouble over here what's the matter
can you help me get home
damn you could have been special but
they've done nothing positive would you
get the [ __ ] exercising he's had a
positive effect on me
oh really uh guys home me really oh
[Music]
Jesus Christ
sir I apologize for my five-year-old
child bad boy you sit there and eat your
fish nothing see nothing okay ready I'm
the funnies Fraulein what the [ __ ] hey
be careful with that huh no it's okay
it's not water and my [ __ ] nose came
off some other last line was like I
don't think we needed the effort no no I
don't like it when people unnecessarily
are like the use of the word [ __ ]
what cuz it it makes it time I kept
trying yeah sound you know adults or
something it's [ __ ] stupid
like what [ __ ] would they do that [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] Hall ma losting I mean
I'm feeling about this trailer the way I
was feeling about the first movies
trailer is like it's probably gonna be
funnier than the trailers but this
trailers kind of like all obvious jokes
to me oh yeah that was a problem at half
of the other trailers yeah it's like
been there done that yeah because the
thing about Seth MacFarlane's humor is
that it's really interspersed where it's
like you'll have some like really witty
or sharp a really sophisticated jokes
but between every one of those is also
like a really obvious or like a poop
joke or something well yeah I feel like
when he does that though it's often
times where I used to work a lot better
back then yeah it's making fun of like
that content of someone who likes fart
jokes yeah I screwed jokes but with this
sometimes it's like it looks like he
thinks that's actually funny and not
making fun of the fact yeah yeah you
know like that's not I think I think
self MacFarlane like generally
appreciates a bit of lowbrow humor cuz
there's always a bit of like really
lowbrow obvious you myrrh in anything he
does and it seems like he has the
philosophy of like we will throw every
joke ours
I'm sure the movie will be fun
regardless yeah out of all the trailers
I've seen this has the most energy to it
and I think that as long as it's fun and
entertaining if it gets a few laughs
I'll be satisfied this doesn't have to
be like a [ __ ] amazing picture so as
long as it's better than a million ways
to die I won't be happy this might feel
more like a cohesive movie Ted was
better directed I think that a million
ways to die and that's because he's not
on camera - he spent years on Ted - but
also I think there's that thing of like
he just does the voice so he can
actually just focus on bigger director
well anyway guys thanks for tuning into
the real rejects you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out cheer
cheer cheer Gerry's playlist movie movie
reviews on there and you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter where
if we get enough followers we can get
product placement but instead of making
a sex joke about product placements
let's do a shout out oh it's one of
those Mike willows t v-- hi Ryan and
Koch a huge fan of the channel just a
random question Rico there we go here we
go we would go here we go guys ever
consider doing your own audio commentary
oh that's what he started for films or a
podcast series that is what he started
my earphones are ready that [ __ ] would
be awesome also a shadow will be awesome
too but no biggie well you just got a
shout out Mike Willow TV uh yeah to
answer your question Jerry got started
of Dhinka Stubbs which is odd cast and I
will be coming on there soon you will
thank you as far as you go Mike Willow
TV Mike Willow TV is a YouTube channel
dedicated to him forming all kinds of
different dildos from taking sculptures
of other men and if he's also got
arrested cuz he tried it on a boy once
oh was not good don't know Mike willow I
was right not me not me it's Mike Willow
doing the sick things and save the sick
stuff yeah pervert but you keep doing
what you got to do No